el presidente de la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas de ecuador
leonidas iza fue detenido la madrugada
de este martes en el segundo día de
protestas convocadas por los movimientos
indígenas en contra del gobierno
nacional en reclamo a 10 peticiones que
contemplan la reducción de precio de
combustibles y la regulación de precios
de todos los productos de la cesta
básica entre otros
muy mal porque el pueblo está reclamando
y todo el mundo nos meten presos y estoy
muy mal porque hubo una persona que sale
a defender al pueblo la meten rápido
preso eso está muy mal y queremos que
mejor si ya no funciona bien el gobierno
pues porque que deje que otro venga que
funcione bien
hay gente social no se encuentra el
gobierno y yo les responsabilizó y no
soy político señor guillermo las no soy
político les responsabilizó al señor
presidente de la república de que tiene
que responder por todos los dirigencia
acaso no nacen después de capturar a una
persona y no dicen dónde tiene frente a
la sede de la unidad de flagrancia
seguras le haría si esas se han
concentrado para demandar su libertad y
han hecho un llamado a radicalizar las
protestas que hasta ahora habían
contemplado a permanecer en los
territorios
creamos igual ya hacer el llamado a
todas las organizaciones sociales a
todos los hermanos jóvenes
universitarios a que vengan a exigir la
libertad de nuestro hermano de nuestro
compañero a leonidas iza además también
a exigir que derroque todas esas medidas
económicas que nos han venido acechando
al país que nos han venido acechando a
toda la ciudadanía en todo el ecuador
el presidente de la república emitió un
pronunciamiento donde aseguró que se
iniciará la detención de los autores
intelectuales y materiales de las
protestas aseguró que no permitirán la
paralización de servicios ni bloqueos de
vías además el ejecutivo expresó que
está dispuesto a volverse a sentar en
diálogo con la dirigencia indígena luego
de tres encuentros previos en el año
2021 paralelamente 17 provincias se
mantienen activas en protestas mientras
que cada sector se atribuye el éxito o
el fracaso de las movilizaciones en el
ecuador